merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à monsieur arnaud viala merci monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre c'est mon incompréhension
profonde est totale et celle de nos
concitoyens médusés que je souhaite vous
livrer dans notre hémicycle
il n'y a pas de crise institutionnelle
déclaré vous à l'envi juste un premier
ministre qui veut se porter candidat à
la présidentielle contre son président
de la république juste des anciens
ministres chaque jour plus nombreux eux
mêmes candidats contre leur ancien
premier ministre justin président de
l'assemblée nationale qui enjoint son
premier ministre à se porter candidat
contre son président mais à part ça pas
de crise institutionnelle nous y croyons
tous vous en oubliez même que nous
sommes un état d'urgence
et vous avez vous même annoncé que nous
le resterons que nos policiers exténuant
battu le pavé pour vous crier leur
besoin de considération et leur
difficulté d'exercice de leurs missions
que l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
vous attendent et que reçoivent est il
de votre part le 10 novembre dernier une
circulaire les procureurs au commissaire
de police
les obligeant à appliquer cinq jours
après des mesures archi favorable aux
prévenus dans toutes les procédures des
lourdeurs insupportable dans les
enquêtes des retranscriptions que leur
logiciel ne permettent même pas sans
parler du scandale des
dysfonctionnements des systèmes
d'écoutés téléphoniques
alors me direz-vous il s'agit de
l'europe non le premier ministre d'un
pays que le terrorisme a frappé si
durement ne peut pas se contenter de
transposer décisions technocratiques
ap secondes il doit les infléchir et a
minima comme 20 pays européens l'ont
fait en différé signer dès l'application
ma question est simple monsieur le
premier ministre faudra-t-il qu'un
nouveau drame frappe la france pour que
les plus hautes autorités de notre état
sortent enfin de leur chicaya
politiciens et s'occupe des français de
leur sécurité et de leur force de
l'ordre
merci la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre manuel valls
monsieur le député
la première partie de votre question
était plaisant à entendre
on ne savait pas à qui elle s'adressait
tout à fait le président l'assemblée
nationale ne pouvant pas répondre je me
préparais je me dévouer pour vous pour
vous répondre
mais honnêtement la fin de votre
question vous plaît ne pose un vrai
problème
face au terrorisme fasseur aux actes
terroristes que la france a subi les
dizaines de morts de blessés de victimes
parce que notre pays a été profondément
traumatisé par ce qu'il y à une menace
lourde sur nous sur de nombreux pays
européens dans le monde
face à cela est-ce qu ici au moins
l'assemblée nationale comme nous avons
su le faire à chaque fois sur ce sujet
là comme c'est le cas dans de nombreux
pays
est-ce que nous ne pourrions pas être
digne est la hauteur de la menace et de
ce que les français attendent tout de
même nous pouvons bien sûr les uns et
les autres et c'est normal diverger un
retraité un sur de nombreux sujets et
nous l'avons vu il y a un instant c'est
la force d'ailleurs de notre pays d'une
démocratie de débattre de continuer à
débattre sur les orientations que chacun
va proposer aux pays dans quelques mois
parce que c'est le destin de la france
qui est en jeu sur l'éducation sur le
modèle républicain sur le modèle social
sur notre vision de l'état et des
services publics
mais comme chacun d'entre vous j'en suis
convaincu j'ai une conviction c'est
parce que comme nous sommes en guerre en
tout cas le terrorisme nous mène cette
guerre parce que nous avons des soldats
engagés des militaires dont je veux
encore salué l'engagement et l'héroïsme
c'est vrai au sahel c'est vrai au levant
parce que le forces de sécurité forces
de sécurité et magistrats ensemble lui
contre le terrorisme parce qu'il y a ce
dont j'ai regardé ce que disait encore
la presse de cet après-midi sur les
risques que représente ce qui
aujourd'hui combattent nos forces et
combattre nos valeurs au levant face à
cela tout de même monsieur le député
dire que le gouvernement le président la
république le gouvernement n'a pas pris
la mesure de ce que nous sommes en train
de connaître s'est divisée or la
division c'est précisément ce que
cherchent les terroristes et moins
inlassablement je serais pour l'unité et
le rassemblement
face au terrorisme merci monsieur le
premier